The second component is the behavioral component. And this refers to the ways
in which I behave towards the Red Wings. Well obviously I buy a lot of Red
Wings material. If the Red Wings are on TV, I'll watch a game. If I don't have
access to a TV, I'll listen to them on the radio. When the Red Wings come to
town, I'll buy a ticket and go see them. And this year, I even went to the
hotel where they stayed so I could to try to meet some of my Red Wings.
Obviously, I have a strong behavioral component in my attitude towards the Red
Wings. And the third component is the cognitive component. And this refers to
the rational thoughts and beliefs that make up my attitude towards the Red
Wings. So here, I know things such as how many Stanley Cup championships we
won, 11. When we first started the league in 1926. I know the famous Red Wing
players, such as Gordie Howe, Ted Lindsay, Steve Yzerman, Brendan Shanahan,
Nick Lindstrom. I know all the players' names and numbers. I know the rules of
the game, I know the coaches, and I even know the hometown announcers. All
those are cognitive components of my attitude towards the Red Wings. Let's go
back and finish up this part on attitudes.